welcome back it's time to surprise
alicia and her sister tiffany throughout
the hour they've been getting a tour of
our building and are about to enter the
studio and we have to be quiet because
they have no idea that we're filming
this is so cute
oh wow oh hi hi
oh
hi oh hi lisa
oh my god
oh my god
and guess what you're on camera too
it's so nice so nice to meet you oh my
goodness oh my gosh
you're here it's your show i'm so
excited to meet both of you oh my gosh i
just love what you're doing in the world
by the way i'm obsessed with your logo
too i'm a nut for graphics oh my god you
made it herself y'all made it myself yes
i made the logo myself and we're
obsessed with you like everything flower
your love for the environment and
everything so our favorite movie yes
ever after yeah so we are so
obsessed well and sisters is my entire
universe now because i have two
daughters so it rules every move i make
and i loved reading about how is it true
you walked off a subway and like saw
this space and
something a light went off yes i was
traveling like with my sister we were
coming back home and so there was like
this environmental space in our
neighborhood where weeds were up to
everyone's ways and there was like trash
and people were using it as a dumping
ground and so i decided that i wanted to
do something about it and improve that
environmental space so that the
community could use it for like access
to transportation gardening and so that
started my organization
and i mean i really want to learn from
you because i feel like um you know
sometimes we look at things that we
would like to change but you actually
went ahead figured it out changed it and
then continued the work on and on and on
so
i mean i feel like we have a lot to
learn from you
thank you so much um i mean the only
thing i could say is like everything
starts with one small step sometimes we
don't think that one small action will
have a ripple effect but doing one small
thing like helping a neighbor helping
clean up environmental space can help
improve communities and help improve our
community environment so just one small
thing at a time i guess so you did that
and then you kept going and you've done
more spaces right so i do spaces
throughout new york city in every
borough and i connect with other
community leaders or people who are like
hey i have an environmental project i
need help so i give them tools resources
help them with everything that i wish
that i had helped with starting out and
now that field that you walked out of
that subway that day and had the light
bulb go off what is it like now so now
like it's a commuter path there so like
it connects all the neighborhoods with
access to the train so it's no longer a
dirt path it's no longer weeds to the
hip and people could get to garden and
go out and enjoy the space young people
get to play there so it's a beautiful
space now
i'm so impressed with you
i mean oh my gosh are you guys close you
look so much alike i told you guys
we're very close we live together
like we're obsessed with you as well
because like we bought our first home
but we've renovated the whole thing
ourselves yeah
furniture everything yeah so we do like
environmental spaces but we also like
yes she's a one-man show like i'm just
like oh she helps me
on project days i help out yeah
not only do i help my daughters have the
relationship that you guys have one day
but since you love being together i'm
hoping that you don't mind if i take you
both to los angeles for our premiere
show
yes
[Applause]
guess who our first guest is it's
jennifer aniston
i know i freak out over her so hard
i love her so much yes we love friends i
love friends we love jennifer innocent i
love friends i love all of her movies i
just love her i'm so excited because
she's someone like i'm never not going
to want to hang on every word
um so
uh i have these suitcases for you
um that are producer alex clark uh
thoughtfully chose in our signature
yellow we love that you can throw all
your stuff in it and we're flying you to
la and you're gonna be there in the
audience and the premiere show as our
special guest oh my goodness thank you
thank you so much this is amazing
thank you so much i actually um want to
take that kind tennis ball you just
tossed over into our court and throw it
right back onto yours we think that you
guys are amazing
and this is going to be so much fun
all right l.a here we go
and then you can keep teaching me how to
look at things that we want to shift and
change and get on top of actually doing
it and not just dreaming about it yeah i
think that's important i'm i'm excited
to teach you i mean i could learn so
much for you so like that means so much
to me so yes i'd be more than happy to
all right let's do
[Applause]
all right alicia and tiffany i'm gonna
see you guys this monday september 13th
for our season two premiere on the
historic paramount lot in wonderful
hollywood we're gonna have a great
weekend see you soon thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]